I think it's about time we go over to
what may be one of the most nightmarish
stories I've ever seen yes I already
have a headache here Marvel introduces
new warriors safe space and snowflake
this is not a joke I thought this was a
joke
I thought you were joking me when I saw
us on Twitter I was like haha they're
making fun of Marvel for getting woke
and then I watched the video the
introductory trailer where the man
explains why we're gonna take back safe
space and snowflake and make them heroes
who are apparently twins who are a tad
incestuous okay that's that's me being
hyper car lines okay I just seated that
near okay let me see the picture so
first here's snowflake and save space
here's the first thing I want to say if
you like this I got no beef
by all means buy the stuff like I'm glad
I'm glad you're getting you know content
that you want I really don't care
sure I think so I think it's a bad idea
my things always like this though dude
if they want to make a product like
asparagus flavored ice cream maybe
somebody want to buy it yeah I'm not
gonna rag on someone front of buying buy
asparagus flavored ice cream I think
it's weird I would want it but in this
instance I look at this and I'm like
this is silly I will not buy it and when
they don't make money
well then maybe they'll stop doing it
yeah when when you've been talking about
you know make something new for for this
I didn't mean this yeah exactly like
something cool something no actually
super hero I don't know I'm not think
about this and was just like no no no I
I'm glad I don't know what do warriors
is either what is this so the new war is
actually like a long-standing comic I
guess okay no I'm totally cool this um
I'm gonna criticize it I'm gonna make
fun of it we're gonna rag on it but
that's just my opinion it doesn't mean
that if you like it you know you
shouldn't and you can't go and buy it if
you write hey man see hey look we're
about freedom here you go do your thing
don't anyone tell you to canter can't do
meanwhile I'm gonna be making fun of
this product judging this yeah but here
but but you made a good point they often
try and take old heroes and then turn
them into woe caricatures exactly and
that's stupid this makes something new
this is something new that so here's
what's disconcerting
you got all these characters this guy is
apparently screentime I guess his thing
is that like Oh screen time he's
connected to Google like I'm not kidding
like I guess it's his power so yeah he
lingual loses his power yeah like it's
in his brain and so he can see memes or
something oh I can see but then you have
these these people right here that are
like embracing each other lovingly they
are twins yeah and the weird thing is if
you look at them you're like this one is
clearly male and this one is clearly
female oh I'm sorry
this one is non-binary doesn't mean
anything you can't just say you're
something if you're clearly definitively
female I guess you could you can call
yourself whatever you want whatever man
this is that's just me you do think I'm
here for the hem careful
well no I always want to make sure I'm
clear that like I'm not I'm always want
people to do their thing you know what I
mean it's funny it says there's a line
that said most twins are psychic but
we're psychic er well it's on it's where
I get twins all twins are psychic but
we're psychic Uri wow that's amazing
writing what their powers yeah weird
apes save space has the ability to make
barriers around other people because he
can make a safe space and snowflake can
create giant or like you know snowflake
shuriken to throw up people I guess that
sounds like a like a bad persons thing
like you're gonna what are you gonna do
with them you're gonna kill somebody
melt and no one's gonna know who killed
him well I mean how did this person die
there's a gash in their in their chest
they bled out but how did it happen
there's no weapon so the thing about it
is mm not every here right away with
murder like but what about Wolverine you
know yeah okay yeah he's got metal claws
and he can slice you up mmm that's what
does he slices people up and he does it
well yes so so look I don't I don't I
don't care about their powers I will say
that in the Marvel Universe
these are anything but Omega level this
is these are pathetic powers as far as
I'm concerned the Marvel
purrs died with Tony Stark yep when he
died
yep I was like oh cool well that was a
good run that well the MCU at least okay
yeah there's been a lot of weird stuff
happening in the Marvel Universe for a
while and before this but this is like
you know I don't want to say jumping the
shark what would be like 10 times
jumping the shark jumping the shark NATO
in space in space yes it would be like
if the Fonz so you know jumping the
shark comes from yeah yeah yeah we like
if the Fonz's on the moon and he jumped
over a Martian shark and then when he
jumped he never landed and just flew
away and I started playing like I start
playing music and it showed him like
traveling through space that's what this
is like they were criticized for getting
woke and making awful comics so they
were like let's lean into it you know
let's go home you thought it was bad
before hold on hold my beer is that yeah
screen time is bad snowflake screen time
is bad all of those are bad terms
they're leaning hard dude screen time
and they're diverse too of course yes
that just feels lazy to me I know
they're just like we need something new
what should we do
who's got some ideas oh I got it screen
time you know it's got the power of
Google it's like oh that's great let's
just run with it like wait what you
thought it was a good idea yeah screen
time what let's read about these these
I'm gonna do air quotes for Heroes all
right it's not fair to call them heroes
Lucas Vecchio a meme obsessed super teen
whose brain became connected to the
Internet after becoming exposed to his
grandfather's experimental Internet
gasps yes terrible dude this sounds like
it's a little kid it was like five yeah
and just like the Internet guess and he
breathed it in and now he can see memes
do you think that's who's sitting at the
table and the guys like right more right
yeah right ideas yeah you're great now
he can see augmented reality and
real-time maps and can instantly Google
an effect does this make him at make him
effectively a genius he sure acts like
it does I wanted to have I wanted to
have teen characters who felt as now as
the new warriors in the 1990s explains
kibble Smith I got a stop right there
the dude's name is kibble Smith Will
Smith yep
like Elaine much kibble Smith Cable
Smith
it sounds very what's the right word low
tea you know it is the video we watch I
think that's the guy the New Warriors
have been zeitgeist characters from the
beginning you get edgy skateboarding
Knight Thrasher in the 1990s and the
reality TV team the 2000s and now and
2020 we have new warriors who have never
grown up without the Internet and one
character who appears to essentially
live inside it the word screen time is
only ever used in a sort of restrictive
sense and because we're doing a story
about teenage rebels a lot of the names
are about teens fighting against labels
that are put on them what if you call
yourself a superhero name don't be are
you implying that they're fighting
against being called the name they want
to be called it would make sense
actually because people are nuts these
days so with screen time we liked the
idea that he has infinite screen time
wait what you know what I think it is no
I think it's I think it's I think it's
more obvious than this they have no idea
what's going on Oakley they write they
Google searched they went on tumblr and
they read a bunch of tumblr yeah and
they were like let's go with it
yeah alright people say I don't want
this here's the the lovingly embraced
twins who apparently one is non-binary
even though she's very clearly female
with you know she's got arrests and whoa
whoa you're just assuming non-binary one
no it is I don't know
psychic twins all twins are psychic but
we're psychic earth there's that
five-year-old snowflake a cryo kinetic
can materialize snowflake shaped
shuriken projectiles for throwing safe
space can materialize pink force fields
but he can't inhabit them himself the
reflex only works if he's protecting
others they're hyper aware of modern
culture and optics and see they're super
heroic as a post-ironic meditation on
using violence to combat bullying oh
what they're literally an tyfa oh my god
using violence to combat bullying so
they're bullies yeah they're probably
streaming this no okay I'll be fair like
if there was a bully and you socked him
one like
as a difference from you know being a
bullying stopping uh they seem like
they're not they seem like bullies
yeah they do they totally do I mean
we'll see snowflake and safeSpace are
the twins the writer says and their
names are very similar to screen time
it's this idea that these are terms that
get thrown around on the internet that
they don't see as derogatory they take
those words and kind of wear them as
badges of honor well that's because
they're dorks yes save spake is a safe
space is a big burly sort of
stereotypical jock he can create force
fields but he can only trigger them if
he's protecting somebody else snowflake
is non-binary and goes by they them and
as the power of floor Bo and as the
power to generate individual
crystallized snowflake shape check ins
the connotations you know what I'm sorry
I got to stop right now as someone of
Asian descent I take serious offense to
their use of the word shuriken for their
weird ideology and no I'm gonna have to
call them and get this guy fired let's
start a camp am kidding yeah the
connotations of the word snowflake in
our culture right now are something
fragile and this is a character was
turning into something sharp snowflake
is the person who has the more offensive
power and save space is the person who
has the more defensive power the idea is
that they they would mirror each other
and complement each other now wow being
negatively be negative is a vampire and
it's so lazy you know how he gets his
power he gets a blood transfusion as a
kid from morbo Morbius sorry now more
about their Morbius it's like oh he got
he's a nice vampire trailblazer the
morbidly obese Native American woman a
regular kid regular kid I mean I don't I
guess I America in America you know a
regular kid scooped up into the world of
teenage superheroing her magic backpack
is actually a pocket dimension with
seemingly infinite space that explains
you know the size from which she can
pull out useful or random objects it's
not always under her control she claims
to get her power from God but not the
God you're thinking of because that
would be offensive
she's a group she's a group home and
foster kid who was volunteering at a
Senior Center
when this mysterious threat shows up and
Knight Thrasher runs to the rescue and
because she helps him she ends up in the
crosshairs of this new outlaw
law Trailblazer wants to help people but
she doesn't think of herself as a
superhero yet kibble Smith concludes the
Marvel unit kibble Smith the Marvel
Universe is a reflection of our own and
when a new law gets put into place it
affects people in unforeseen ways Oh
what is she like undocumented or
something probably so here's what I love
like he's right these characters are a
reflection of people today and they're
trying to cater to them it's a
reflection of like the jokes were some
people remember when people wish right
it feels like a joke still I say still
and I'm having a hard time believing
this is actually happening it's too
early for April yeah I don't believe it
I don't believe I just is it we're
reading marvel.com
I can't believe this this is crazy
hold on remember how like they would use
they used to draw superheroes where they
were they would essentially draw them as
naked and then just color their bodies
so you would see like contours and like
their butt cracks and everything now
it's like I mean I guess they still kind
of do that I mean they're wearing
skintight clothes it's kind of weird
yeah but it was supposed to be that
there was like burgeoning like muscles
and strength and the women were like
busty and beautiful they were the
paradigm you were supposed to want to be
the best yeah she's she's like
dangerously obese she's a trailblazer
you know but my issue with this is
aren't we supposed to be encouraging
people to be healthier and do better
instead we're saying like beautiful but
you know what's funny actually I was
gonna say you know there's rarely do you
see like male superheroes being morbidly
obese I know when people hated that yeah
that for an end game was weird he seemed
out of control I know and it was I
didn't it did not feel like a conclusion
or it made no sense to me I mean I like
endgame for sure but endgame definitely
felt like a so long farewell to them see
you yeah exact like it was over yeah
that's what I'm saying can you imagine
when they bring trailblazer and save
space into the MCU
no one's gonna that would be so amazing
I would definitely go see it you would
absolutely yeah we'd have to so we can
rant about it on our show and make fun
of it and throw the screen
whoa whoa whoa whoa don't waste popcorn
bruh yeah that's a good point I'm a big
fan of corn dude oh dude let's be honest
no I don't know if you know that about
me if these characters right into a
movie if these characters are made into
a movie it would bomb horribly but I
would be the first person to see amazing
it would be so woke it'd be but no no
but it's like good it would be hilarious
it probably would like what's the fetch
it gonna wait is this a comedy because
that then it makes sense then no it is
not these very important this is serious
signal so they're a tank you yeah you
know do people still buy this stuff I
don't know I don't think so like I don't
think when Kamala's law goes into effect
in the highly anticipated one-shot
outlawed super heroics will be left to
the adults and underage heroes will be
banned unless they have official
government assigned to Mentors
that's where the new warriors come in
what to break the law yeah whatever I
mean it sounds like they're literally an
tyfa you know we use violence to stop
violence yeah and also we're overweight
I take issue with trailblazer I do I'm
sorry I gotta say it I I I'm look if you
want to read about snowflake and safe
save space it's fine they're both
physically fit looking people you can do
or believe or car stuff whatever you
want I don't care man you do your thing
what's America is all about pursuit of
happiness whatever whatever floats your
boat you know and they're in shape
trailblazers happy Tim yeah but trail
trailblazer is a character that's going
to be encouraging young people to to
being accepting of unhealthy lifestyles
and gluttony and hedonism she's happy so
to an extent to an extent you're correct
I agree I'm playing doubled up no no but
you're right you're right I will
absolutely accept if somebody look I
know a lot of people and I posted
something about you know people should
be fit and I got a I got you know
several over people you know tweeting at
me saying like I like being overweight I
like doing these things and I'm like use
bots on brother but it's no one told you
you can't do it yeah you shouldn't be
encouraging other people to do that
right and they acknowledge it but listen
man if there's somebody who in their
life they want to be overweight they
like eating the way they do there you go
whatever man do you think you're on
health care and do your own thing but we
should absolutely not be in
would not be encouraging young people to
to live this way I mean it's gonna cause
it causes cancer it's like one of the
leading causes of cancer as obesity
heart disease so like you will die yeah
exactly not good for you what's the end
result then I don't know the people just
live unhealthy awful lives and encourage
it more and hopefully Marvel gets a new
writer actually no you're only getting
worse man that actually knows what
comics are like it's only getting worse
it's like like and also knows what the
people want because I don't think the
people want it this is this is like the
two percent of even and then two percent
of that they're like appeasing such a
small it's like it's like Sanders going
after the the transgender vote in
prisons house Warren bars Warren was
going on or whatever it doesn't matter
the politics why why are you going after
that why are you going after that little
market you know when safes the market is
here but you know we got to appease
these people dude I think think about
the popular comics I mean like the MCU
has been pretty good but look at how
popular Iron Man Thor and Captain
America were yeah and they were they
were white males buff tall while not
rabid any junior he's not buff but you
know he's Tony Stark but he's don't he
start his charisma no no no Tony Stark
is is it is a dick like that's literally
whose character is yeah he has charisma
though sure sure
yeah but he's like they made a movie
like Tony Stark is supposed to be kind
of a bad dude yeah he's a he's a bad
dude but he's a superhero
yeah that was kind of the point of the
character could they make someone that
was a completely detestable individual
but was still the hero yeah and people
love it and Robert Downey doing an
amazing job but but seriously you know
Captain America Thor Iron Man
there's stereo they're like a sort of
stereotypical isn't the right word but
they're like okay well it's it's the
hero's journey to an extent it's very
predictable stuff it's classic it's and
it's a white male lead and people love
it and they made millions and billions
and billions you know and now it feels
like it's kind of over I mean you know
with endgame sure you know we can say
kind of ended but home far from home
spider-man
I thought movies yeah they're great yeah
so they're gonna be doing more I'm sad
for that yeah I'm excited for the next
Doctor Strange stuff yes if they put
snowflake in safe space anywhere near
the MCU at all like I'd probably just
stop going yes if they made a new
warriors movie with them I'd be like go
see it I'd be all excited like there's
gonna be hilarious
what if they insert them into that force
it into the MC I mean look that Thor is
already bad enough like people didn't
like dark world okay I like dark world
that was fine Thor dark well yeah yeah
oh yeah and then Ragnarok yeah that was
okay I like rock at Ragnarok started is
where they they saw the the silliness
they could embrace yeah and then with an
game they were like let's go overboard
and it destroyed the character of Thor
yeah that was not his arc he was it's
crazy to me that his homeworld is
destroyed and he makes it through yeah
his regard is wiped out and he's fine
yeah and then Thanos snaps the universe
and he becomes a whiny sniveling little
baby ya know he was supposed to be king
how could Thank You sirs like it didn't
make it any clearer but he didn't blame
himself for for Asgard being destroyed
but he blamed himself because he didn't
get a chance to kill and he didn't let's
go so I you know I can I can kind of see
it I always tried to look at the other
side and it's like yeah but you're
totally right though he that wasn't Thor
like you know right it was just not his
character you know yeah but that's it
that's his art now that now there was
gonna be a girl right and that's why I
think the MCU is really over didn't that
actually happen in the comics then
people hated it a female Thor yeah Jane
Jane Foster becomes Thor okay in the
comics yes yeah it actually so now Jane
Foster is gonna be Lady Thor in the
movie apparently and I guess people are
gonna not like it but hey it could be
good I look at the noir film so Captain
Marvel made money and it's and if it's
Taika Waititi then I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be good so the one thing I'll say
it's all this silliness snowflake and
safe space look I'll tell you what man
they might as well make a clown I call
them like Captain clown and it's no just
clown just clown my name is I need in
any has no powers he's just a clown yeah
any
it's villains by throwing pies or a
bright orange man
that's orange man bad oil for it just go
for it yeah the orange man
no no but little bleeding snowflake and
safely is such a ridiculous caricature
of superhero comic characters yeah they
may as well have just made a clown feels
like it the colorful cartoon the
ridiculous name you know and having
throw pies so how could what what is
this I'll tell you what man I I still
almost just can't believe this is even
real yeah when I first saw this
especially the overweight woman and then
like that I'm gonna reiterate this I'm
trying to point out again like they're
lovingly embraced they're loving embrace
it's so weird
I don't like it you're psychic or that's
weird
they have like a a weird relationship I
don't know I'm not they're not normal
twins as they stated but his horrible
twins are like that maybe maybe twenty
er maybe maybe other people just know
better than me but like if you were a
fraternal twin with like would you like
hug and embrace like that I know some
twins and are they weird no they're
friends yeah they're siblings sometimes
I can yeah but they don't hold each
other yeah yeah that's weird
yeah Marvel is just boo I look I'll be
honest though I don't read the comics
neither do i that's but not anymore
right it's been a long time I used to
and so that's it they know they know
that you and I don't care and so they
don't care that we're making fun of it
there's gonna be some tumblr kids
Republic oh cool non-binary yeah
snowflake
shoo-shoo I'm throwing snowflakes mom
can you give me the snowflake thing so I
can throw snowflakes and be non-binary
and she's gonna beg okay and he's in a
little birthday party and someone's
gonna get in a safe space and they're
trying to popularize it Hey look I've
got my safe space action figure you're
you're known as Steve URIs - it's gonna
be funny to you it's gonna be funny when
some little girls like I need to start
eating more if I want to be a like
Trailblazer and then their parents may
be like why is she gaining so much
weight she's trying to be like her
favorite hero and then she's not gonna
be able to do anything close to what Cho
blazer does because she's gonna be
overweight and unable to actually do
stuff what does she do she pulls stuff
out of her back
that's amazing that's any kid
Trailblazers this is what they're trying
to do though they're trying to figure
out how they can sell comics to the fat
kids at the back pack yeah I guess so
yep that's what it's all about that's
one of the reasons why they have this
big push for diversity it's not because
they think they're morally right to do
so it's because they're like how do we
get comic books in the hands of these
groups make characters for them they're
kind of trying to target and well I by
like ostracizing all of the people that
used to like they're calm but sales are
down okay so here's what they're
thinking
maybe they don't want to be blockbuster
video they want to be Netflix and that
means if there are nails are dropping
their attitude is like flipped the
business there's something else even if
it's very different so I don't see this
working I mean I don't know we're gonna
buy this Dora the diabetic someone said
that was a great comment I just I just
randomly saw that on the way through
those we're instantly banned we're gonna
get in trouble now thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you